All right.
Let's get right into audience questions for
the week.
The first one, I've gotten it from a bunch
of different people since the Corona virus
pandemic got going.
The question is, is this bitcoins big opportunity?
Will the Corona virus recession lead to bitcoins?
Huge adoption and also valuation.
So full disclosure, I've already said when
all of this started, one of the moves I made
was I did pick up some additional bitcoin
and I've had some for years that I've just
been holding.
And my thought is maybe it's a hedge that
is not correlated to the broader market.
So it's conceivable that it's a hedge.
It may not be.
And in fact, on some days that the stock market
has been down hugely.
So has Bitcoin.
So I have no special knowledge.
I did that, but I'm clueless.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Here is my thought.
What is it that would have to happen with
the dollar for a lot of people to go to Bitcoin
who are not already in the space?
What would have to happen to the euro for
people to go into Bitcoin?
Because this really is is more a question
of currency than it is of recession.
And why do I say that?
The reason I say that is you get the tech
adoption barriers aside.
Imagine that people just as easily and of
course, that that it's just not going to happen.
But imagine that people much more easily could
get and use bitcoin so that it becomes more
comparable to getting and using U.S. dollars
or euro or whatever your local currency is.
If you get the tech barriers out of the way,
people are only going to be looking to bitcoin
as a flight to safety if their country's currency
either becomes much more volatile so that
it matches or approximate the volatility of
bitcoin.
Because remember, bitcoin is very volatile
and we've seen it in the last couple of years
be worth as much as nineteen thousand dollars
per coin at the end of 2017, early 2018.
I believe it's been all the way down to five.
That's a four X swing.
U.S. dollar, of course, has fluctuations,
but they are far smaller than what we've seen
in Bitcoin.
So one thing that would need to happen if
we solve the tech barriers to more people
getting involved with bitcoin is the volatility
of bitcoin would have to come down while the
volume volatility of the dollar goes up.
That would be one thing.
Secondly, there would have to be some real
evidence that aside from what your investment
choices are with dollars, that going to bitcoin
is going to be safer over the long term than
sticking with dollars.
And this is more than just volatility.
Only if there is a signal that the dollar
will not only be volatile but might really
lose so much value that your purchasing power
will be decreased.
Would people be encouraged to go and move
money to bitcoin?
And in addition to that.
If it's not going to be useful for buying
things that you need, particularly if the
corona virus pandemic extends and we have
supply chain interruptions that are not currently
expected, and we have difficulties obtaining
certain products simply with U.S. dollars
on Web sites like Target.com and Amazon, etc.
I don't think that there is going to be a
wholesale move in the direction of Bitcoin.
My sense is that the move to bitcoin, which
over the last couple of weeks has seen bitcoin
ascend in value and maybe by the time this
clip publishes that will have reversed.
I think that it is a fraction of the population
around the world that has said, hey, if governments
can be really poor at dealing with the pandemic,
maybe I shouldn't be all in with their currency
either.
And I'll pick up some bitcoin.
I believe that that is the lion's share of
the move to bitcoin that we have seen over
the last month or so.
If people really were saying, I've got to
get out of my state's kirp my country's currency
and get over to Bitcoin.
You would have seen such a larger increase
in the value of Bitcoin than the one that
we've seen.
So that's that's my view.
Volatility would have to go up drastically
for government backed currencies, down for
bitcoin.
The technical barriers would have to be solved.
The corona virus situation would really have
to extend longer than even the best models
now suggest it would.
And then in that case, yes, maybe this will
prove to be Bitcoin's big opportunity.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
That's what I'm seeing so far.